des routes négligées sous-financées et
vieillissante voilà le portrait que fait
CAA Québec dans sa huitième campagne
intitulée Les pires routes du Québec en
première position la rue Georges à
Gatineau en deuxième la route 329 à
Saint-Adolphe d'hourdes et il y a aussi
la route des fondateurs au Saguenay et
le chemin Sainte-Foy à Québec entre
autres
c'est la deuxième fois que la rue
Georges à Gatineau est qualifiée de pire
route du Québec c'est juste des trous
partout
un paysage enchanteur à Saint-Adolphe
d'award mais sa route principale la 329
et dans un piteux état des trous partout
et même des affaissements de chaussée le
ministère ce qu'il fait c'est uniquement
de temps à autre du patchage et du
patchage à très des critiques on peut
pas rouler à la limite de vitesse
permise pour les cyclistes rouler sur
cette route est un exercice à haut
risque la route elle est très dangereuse
pour les particuliers
attends la Ville de Montréal n'est pas
épargnée dans ce palmarès 5 rue en
mauvais état sont cités dont la pire la
rue Notre-Dame est suivi de l'Acadie
Christophe Colomb chemin de la Côte de
Liesse et le boulevard Saint-Laurent
notre réseau routier a besoin d'un peu
d'amour je dirais que dans ma manière
que les financée présentement c'est
sous-financé on a annoncé des
investissements de 30 milliards pour les
10 prochaines années or si on voulait
améliorer le réseau du jour au lendemain
il faudrait mettre sur la table 20
milliards de dollars maintenant est-ce
que les routes du Québec sont pires
qu'ailleurs pas vraiment selon CAA
Québec l'état de la chaussée peut varier
d'une province à l'autre évidemment mais
dans l'ensemble c'est similaire au
Québec entre 15 et 25% des routes sont
en mauvais ou très mauvais état selon
ses à Québec la bonne nouvelle c'est que
la situation semble s'améliorer d'année
en année
ici Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada à
sainte-adolphe